many of the things that are roiling our
culture still today the the seeds of
which were were kind of planted at Waco
which is like distrust to the federal
government
um conflicting viewpoints about you know
does God belong in in our society and
not the right to bear arms and so there
are all these fundamental issues which
are you know God and guns and children
in America they've been with us since
the founding of this country they'll be
with us you know through the end but
Waco was a particularly volatile and
explosive example of when things go
horribly wrong you know what that Powder
Keg can be like the bombing of the
Murrah building in Oklahoma City two
years later by Timothy McVeigh is a
direct you know one-to-one uh result of
what happened in Waco there's you know
what happened the school shooting in
Columbine you know people subsequently
being inspired by McVeigh and David
koresh and the arguable missteps of the
government